bonjour à tous aujourd'hui avec mélanie
nous ne sommes pas collègues nous sommes
adversaires deux équipes qui vont
s'affronter pour le combat du meilleurs
desserts de noël et bixente je sais pas
si vous savez montre 8 et 10 millions de
bus ont commandé chaque année ce qui
pousse les pâtissiers à rivaliser
toujours plus d'imagination pour trouver
de nouvelles recettes encore plus
gourmande mélanie vous serez donc dans
l'équipe de la reine astrid et moi même
celle de la pâtisserie fine à versailles
et puis pas plus de mots partons tout de
suite à meudon c'est là où se trouve le
laboratoire de christophe bertrand
[Musique]
christophe versement bonjour bonjour
alors cette année dans vos préparations
vous avez choisi le mucilage de cacao
est ce qu'on peut tout de suite levé le
voile de ce même sillage oui c'est
quelque chose que les consommateurs ne
connaissent pas et qui va être assez
surprenant parce que ils vont donc mangé
une bûche donc la totalité est issu de
la cabosse tout vient de la cabosse et à
l'intérieur du fruit et une petite
pulpeuse blanche qui entoure les fèves
de cacao cette petite pile peau blanche
va servir elle est super sucre et en ça
ressemble à du kiwi l'aloe vera du
litchi là ça sent un peu la banane on
mange des fruits alors on mange du fruit
mais justement alors donc ça veut dire
que sachant que c'est un fruit et comme
il faut manger cinq fruits et légumes
que les jours lorsque vous manger du
chocolat puis ça c'est moi qui l'ait
décidé eh bien ça rentre dans les fruits
et légumes qu'il faut manger tous les
jours ça va donner l'eau à la bouche
votre chef pâtissier matches suspects il
va nous révéler la recette moi je vais
aller du côté du labo et il va falloir
que je résiste je pense que mathieu
bonjour je vends mes amis c'est vous qui
allez nous révéler les secrets de cette
bûche une première étape j'imagine
pourrait alors aujourd'hui on est sur un
but sillage donc on va faire notre
sincère mucilage ou quand notre mucilage
on va la faire chauffer on va le monter
un petit peu en température
je vais gagner un match
j'ai du mal à résister ont soumises
notre moule une petite couche de crème
donc voilà on a le crémeux qui va
apporter un petit peu d'amertume je
viens fermé médicalement notre smooth
donc j'ai fait une gatling rue cacao
petit monde des chocolats fèves de cacao
on savait pas mais il y en a vraiment de
toutes les couleurs et à des verts des
rouges des jaunes des roses verts des
rouges et la vague rock maintenant on
peut savourer on peut savourer ces
moments déguster merci mathieu les bus
sont déjà disponibles dans les boutiques
de la reine astrid bixente ah vous de
relever le défi parce que là il ya du
niveau
mélanie vous m'avez demandé du niveau je
vous ai pris au mot il est passé par
alain ducasse la maison dalloyau et
l'hôtel ritz à paris mesdames et
messieurs sébastien serveau bonjour
bonjour donc pourquoi vous êtes vous
lancé dans ce défi d'ouvrir votre propre
institut basse a toujours été un rêve en
fait d'ouvrir une pâtisserie avec avec
ma femme et c'est vrai que j'ai traversé
un petit peu le monde pendant une
dizaine d'années avec mon métier de
consultant international et voilà il
était temps de s'installer et à
versailles c'est vrai que ça nous
correspondait bien sûr le côté chic et
haut de gamme de la ville au menu
justement 5 buts l'exotique l'impérial
la saint louis et une petite spécificité
une bûche voilà une année oui elle
propose une bûche finesse donc avec un
moulin peu spécifique un peu en forme de
torsades cette année c'est pas le
spéculoos donc des parfums peu régressif
et que tout le monde apprécie en règle
générale je vous propose d'ailleurs
d'aller voir l'étape l'élaboration de
cette bûche tout de suite bien là j'ai
fait en fait un athée et je vais le
verser sur mes pommes pour faire infuser
en fait mais pas alors si on a un autre
mode à but donc c'est bien donc ça ça
doit être taillée vraiment la perfection
pour voilà ils font ça très bien
exactement ensuite je vais piocher dans
mon crime au spéculoos ensuite je vais
prendre mes pommes délicatement je vais
les poser dans mon moule ensuite je vais
refermer donc valu avec votre parti de
biscuits donc là je réalise la mousse
vanille de tahiti donc là on est une
heure plus tard vint cerf a été sorti du
grand froid et on va pouvoir commencer
vraiment l'assemblage clash veut masquer
le moule remonter la mousse sur les
extrémités et ensuite je vais rabattre
un petit peu la moue ses maîtres le
croustillant tu fais la passe est
maintenant grand froid voilà mélanie
notre but c'est maintenant terminé du
côté du niveau je pense que ça va être
difficile de nous départager et vous
qu'est-ce que vous choisissez
[Musique]